my name is Dave I'm a video producer at
Gamescom and I'm going to name some
personas despite never playing the game
so no that's a dreidel with tits on it
what do you see here an ass that's
rebuff foul that's an angry comma that
someone's got their head stuck in a
cupboard and just decided to roll with
it that's the logo for the Hobgoblin
beer taking a dump
he's like why if you want in on me you
mind shut the door
squeezing one out Kate where'd you get
that picture of me have you put gag ones
in the aren't in the game there's a lot
of dicks into it gobbling codpiece bug
scarf star Me's dad he's a big bully
clock beeps crimson thumb the boil of
many faces ah like that one it's a penis
ha ha ha oh dear um incorrect testicle
nope no one I don't want to know
nighttime ham bleep up okay I'm
complicate this game with you it's bad
for you pork scratching is cheap have
you never seen a Jew before sex I'm
Welsh that's the S the other punctuation
one of a sarees and he looks like he's
having a really satisfying poo okay I
feel like I'm having a fever dream keep
that game away from me don't don't bring
that to off any more please that's
disgusting
banned persona